bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8 l'aktu
le journal de la rédaction de tv fil 78
pour faire le tour de l'actualité locale
nous sommes le 5 septembre voici les
titres que nous allons développer ce
soir le blues de la maternologie de
saint-cyr-l'ecole cet établissement qui
s'attache à la dimension psychique de la
maternité et qui prend en compte les
difficultés de la relation mère enfant
pourrait fermer l'association mamans
blues monte au créneau
les habitants de guyancourt s'inquiètent
pour leur sécurité dans le quartier de
villas roire un collectif vient de
lancer une pétition et interpelle les
pouvoirs publics les traditionnel forum
des associations se déroule ce samedi
dans de nombreuses villes yvelinoise
focus à la fin de ce journal sur la
vivacité de ce secteur avec deux invités
l'an est élu à montigny le bretonneux
l'autre à la verrière et l'image du
joueur la voici la rentrée au lycée de
louis bas score à rambouillet de vin
l'entente 17 ans et de son chien guide
gringo le centre mira europe basée dans
le vaucluse lui a offert durant l'été
c'est donc une grande première pour le
jeune homme mal voyants qui va pouvoir
mener une scolarité beaucoup plus
paisible à présent va vous l'entendrez
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure la
maternologie de saint cyr l'école qui
dépend de l'hôpital charcot menacée de
fermeture et une association qui décide
de prendre les choses en main nous
sommes en ligne avec élise marre sang de
bonsoir
bonsoir à vous vous êtes membre du
bureau associatif maman blues je précise
déjà que nous avons sollicité la
direction de cet établissement qui n'a
pas donné suite à nos demandes
d'interview de précisions alors cette
maternologie de san siro plus
précisément l'unité de maternologie
unité d'hospitalisation conjointe
sommaire et bébé pourrait fermer donc
d'ici la fin de l'année pourquoi avez
vous décidé de vous mobiliser et lyse
marsan
mère et enfant et sur l'inspiration à
temps plein et avec la possibilité de
fermeture ou de restructuration se
ferait
zhu qui transcenderait sûrement en une
explication beaucoup plus cicatrisantes
et seulement sur la journée les mamans
rentrerai ou serait fun sans laure délie
donc ce sera un véritable changement
d'approché terre petit ans est tout à
fait en fait la pratique la galerie est
vraiment fondées sur la forme physique
de la maternité et sur le lien entre la
mère et enfant donc les mamans sont
accompagnés et soutenus par une éclipse
solaire mais elle faut vraiment en lien
avec leur bébé elles font pourtant avec
le sont jamais séparés c'est une
pétition que vous avez lancé combien de
signatures à ce jour pour ce courrier
que vous allez ensuite adressé au
ministère des affaires sociales et de la
santé
elles l'ont fait en ligne sur
mesopinions.com et sur la page que nous
avons pas de réaction par rapport à
comment fermeture donc depuis son canapé
lit tous les gens mais maman et papa
mais elle a chanté pour
cette fermeture c'est apparemment une
décision en tout cas peut-être et
réorganisation de la décision du centre
hospitalier et non pas des pouvoirs
publics comme c'est plus souvent le cas
est-ce que déjà ça vous surprend il
qu'est ce que vous avez réussi à rentrer
en contact avec cet établissement
pourrait changer alors malheureusement
avant de tempérer cette action nous
avons envoyé plusieurs courriers à
l'agencé régionale de santé à hauteur de
l'hôpital charcot et à me faire chanter
nous n'avons actuellement aucune réponse
du cabinet de la ministre de la santé
qui est un copié collé en fait du
communiqué phrase de charcot donc qui
reste très évasif sur
la possible fermeture d'une idée ce que
nous savons c'est que faire déjà les
sont supprimés peu à peu pour que je
m'en
fous qu'il soit fait au fur et à mesure
font que les usagers aient leur mot à
dire donc on vous a pas expliqué si
c'était une raison économique ou alors
tout simplement ces deux centrales sont
vraiment de là
le centre de maternologie c'est
finalement une structure assez rare
qu'ils se posent sur ces questions de
difficultés à maternelle avec les
enfants ça concerne une mère sur dix
selon votre association soit 80 mille
personnes comment vous expliquer ces
difficultés qui sont en fait en fait
pourtant ensuite
beaucoup de maires
n'ont jamais donc ce chiffre peut être
étendue
pour cent et la difficulté matérielle
touche toutes les femmes
tous profils de tout horizon parce qu'en
fait la maternité n'est pas seulement
une étape physique et bien une étape
transitoire dans la vie d'une femme a
besoin d'être accompagné
quand
survient une dernière question
concernant votre association vous
intervenez de quelle manière auprès de
ces mamans en difficulté justement
forum par lequel en veillant à soutenir
à former les parents futurs parents
nous essayons aussi de faire connaître
et reconnaître le plus possible la
difficulté maternelle et nous essayons
aussi d'être le relais d'informations
entre les professionnels et les usagers
difficile pour les connell de comprendre
ce qu'est la maternelle et
vécu à des maternelles
avons vécu
merci à vous et lyse marsan 12 est un
nombre du bureau de cette association
maman blues je rappelle donc que cette
maternologie de saint cyr reste menacée
de fermeture ou de réorganisation et
vous avez lancé donc cette pétition
merci à vous en politique est le passage
de messages des leaders de l'udd et y
ait du modem semble être passée parmi
les jeunes centristes du département des
yvelines les jeunes udi et les jeunes
démocrates annonce prendre acte des
déclarations de françois bayroux et de
jean louis borloo qui propose un
rapprochement de leurs deux formations
dans le cadre des prochaines élections
européennes de 2014 il faudra cependant
voir comment pourrait élaborer les
stellistes commune alors que l'udinese
se réclame proches de l'ump et que le
modem a fait le choix du ps lors de la
dernière présidentielle
un tout autre sujet à présent nous
allons parler des incivilités les
incivilités se sont elles ces bruits de
scooter à répétition des maudits trop
fort également des groupes qui
s'approprie des halls d'immeubles et
c'est tout un quotidien qui est
bouleversée des habitants de guyancourt
ont lancé une pétition pour dénoncer les
actes vécu dans leur quartier durant
l'été un courrier qui fait écho à une
lettre adressée au premier ministre en
juillet à part alain ajaj c'est le maire
d'une autre commune celle de la verrière
anthony rech et jonathan vilma
les nuisances dans le quartier de villas
rouag guyancourt des buts il y a deux
ans une vingtaine de jeunes s'amusent à
moto en bas des fenêtres des cailloux
sont jetés cet été les forces de l'ordre
doivent se déplacer à de nombreuses
reprises le problème c'est qu'il ya pas
de dialogue possible c'est que dès qu'on
demande gentiment d'avoir un peu de
silence ou et puis c'est un peu parlé
monfort ou ou pas circuler avec leurs
scooters ces substances fait agresser en
fait verbalement le ster que moi je sors
de chamant me demandent de sortir et
puis pour régler ça au point dans la
nuit du 13 au 14 juillet une dizaine de
véhicules auraient été vandalisé des
poubelles incendiées excédés certains
habitants du quartier lance une pétition
pour faire réagir les pouvoirs publics
munis de 178 signature ils sont reçus
par le maire de guyancourt maire a pris
contact avec la commissaire de tokyo est
en cours pour voir un petit peu
justement augmenté
la présence de la police nationale comme
la présence de police municipale sur le
quartier et les habitants l'ont vu et
nous l'ont dit malgré cette réaction
certains habitants déménager ou pense à
le faire les auteurs de la pétition ont
été reçus ce jeudi par le maire pour
faire un point sur la situation
ces derniers jours le quartier de villas
roy semble s'être calmée
et devancé et sensibilité à répétition
certains plans ça faire appel à des
polices privées comprenait des polices
parallèles ou des milices privées elles
pourraient renforcer l'action des forces
de l'ordre qu'en pensez-vous c'est notre
question du jour de ce 5 septembre
ça existe déjà une police privée
y'a qu'a voir tout ce qui est entrepris
de pour la sécurité pour le gardiennage
donc pourquoi
on crée une alors qu'elles existent déjà
ben c'est bien oui pour la sécurité on
la sécurité des citoyens des assurés du
peuple c'est bien ça je pense que ce
n'est pas souhaitable
parce que des débordements sont à
craindre je pense police privée et de
plus des rivalités entre les deux forces
peuvent a apporté de nombreux problèmes
bien sûr et un sentiment de sécurité
mais je pense pas que ce soit une
solution je pense pas clairement quand
je vois
le personnel de sécurité qui peut
assurer si j'ose dire la sécurité dans
les hypermarchés dans les gares ou dans
les aéroports je pense pas qu'ils
souhaiteraient avait qualifié pour
suppléer à ce que peut faire la police
nationale ou municipale non ça c'est
clair mon nom parce que c'est pas une
bonne idée compte tenu du recrutement
qui fait
vivre avec une déficience visuelle à
handicap d'autant plus grand lorsque
l'on est adolescent et valentin 17 ans
malvoyants revit depuis cet été le
centre mira europe qui s'occupe du
dressage des chiens d'aveuglés vient de
lui offrir gringo la rentrée au lycée
bascans de rambouillet de ce nouveau duo
inséparable elle vient de se dérouler
sans encombre anthony rech et patrick
jacques de dixmude
le pas est encore un peu hésitant mais
après un mois et demi de vie commune ils
sont déjà inséparables
valentin effectué sa première rentrée
scolaire avec gringo son nouveau
compagnon qu'elle arrivait de cela
bernois de deux ans a même transformé
l'élève de terminale économique et
sociale valentin est très à l'écouté de
ce que des personnes king krule ont
changé sont ces horaires d'ailleurs pour
être là l écoute de ses besoins il se
lève plus tôt le matin pour être mal
pour être assure que le chien va manger
il a changé ses horaires avant et et des
horaires d'adolescents je me lève à 13h
et voilà donc là maintenant il a changé
le réveil du matin pour que les chiens
puissent manger à 8h et puis se couche
plus tard pour que le chien est bien
manger à 22 heures mais le réveil
mal voyant de naissance la vue de
valentin est comparable à un oeil dans
un trou de serrure avec seulement
quelques points de lumière gringo est
donc devenu vite ces nouveaux yeux
y en a marre d'avoir presque les mêmes
vues que les autres
monaco était regardée à côté de moi ou
la personne qui me parlent et de l'autre
face de l'autre on va surtout
je voudrais dire regardez
le chemin quoi
la confiance est totale mais les deux
compagnons sont encore en rodage
l'autonomie complète elle s'acquiert
vraiment pour les non voyants avec avec
l'expérience avec avec l'âge faut savoir
que c'est quand même très anxiogènes
comme comme handicap le chien va lui
donner la confiance l'envié de commencer
à se déplacer valentin est déjà capable
d'aller chercher le pain seul dans la
ville dans quelques semaines les 17
hectares de son lycée n'auront plus de
secret pour lui
christine vincent génoé la mère de louis
un jeunes adultes autistes elle pratique
depuis un an une nouvelle méthode dead
intensif or au développement la méthode
3i intensif individuel et interactive
est la famille vit sinoise recherche
actuellement des bénévoles pour l'aider
dans les séances quotidiennes catherine
zola tôt pour les précisions
louis est un jeune adulte autistes à
raison de quatre séances d'une heure et
demie chacune il suit une méthode de
développement peu connue la méthode 3i
3i comme intensif individuel interactif
ça se passe dans une salle de jeux qui
aménagé selon la méthode c'est à dire
que il y à une balancelle qui permet à
l'enfant aux jeunes de se balancer de
ceux des tentes qui est très important
dans cette méthode est aussi ça permet
aux bénévoles d'être juste en face de
l'enfant ou du jeune parce qu'on veut ce
qu'on recherche bien sûr c'est le
contact des yeux mais les changes est en
fait c'est comme ça qu'on commence à
créer la relation ce qui est primordial
vraiment laulan
francis est bénévole depuis le mois de
septembre
il vient trois jours par semaine pour
accompagner louis dans son développement
c'est vraiment un partage
ce que j'essaie de faire avec mon ami
louis c est vraiment des coups qui n'est
vraiment une écoute active
essayé à chaque fois à partir d'une de
ces attitudes
d'enchaîner un jeu dans lequel il va
devenir acteur au début je m'amuse et à
prendre sa main comme jack layton tu me
donnes ta mais louise en voilà il
donnait la main et puis après j'ai dit
ouvre tamagotchi on va jouer d'accord tu
l'as tu réponds doigts et c'est pas
parce qu'ils sont là il faut le faire et
oh
ça manquait aux rameaux bon voilà je
sais petit je conseille musée l'a fait
et puis après il devient vraiment acteur
temps en temps c'est lui qui me tend la
main pour que je puisse m mendois campus
l'attraper voilà c'était changer c'est
là où je dis qu'il faut une écoute
active est ce cultivateur sur comment
banon
il s'est redressé il a un meilleur
regard même si à notre avis il y avait
des gens à beauregard mille un bien
meilleur regard il quand il regarde
maintenant les animaux l'escalier par
exemple il y monte ils descendent et
déjà tout seul bien sûr mais il ne
descend beaucoup mieux prend beaucoup
plus de risques avec son corps qu'avant
c'est une méthode qui n'est développé en
france que depuis sept ans
christine lance un appel aux bénévoles
il faut juste
j'allais dire être ouvert d'esprit bien
sûr mais savoir jouer avec un enfant il
n'y a aucune connaissance médicale
paramédicale à avoir thierry morin
actuellement une quinzaine de personnes
se relaient tous les jours du lundi au
dimanche idéalement la famille recherche
une dizaine de personnes qui pourraient
consacrer une heure et demie par semaine
à leur fils louis une formation est bien
entendu proposé
en économie la zone commerciale de
coignières qui depuis 2009 fait face au
départ de son ancien phare la zone du
forum est dédiée au bricolage reprend
enfin son second souffle le point sur
cette zone qui était devenu un vrai
cauchemar pour les quelques commerçants
et qui était resté depuis lors avec
clair combien il y a à peine quelques
mois le forum de coignières ressembler à
ça attention changement de décor par
qu'il refait bâtiment rénové et agrandi
on passe un dernier coup de peinture
mais déjà deux nouvelles enseignantes
ouvert leurs portes décathlon et bah
vous après quatre ans d'attenté cette
rénovation est bien reçue par les
habitants des alentours d'habitude je
n'ai jamais mais je vois qui en fait y'a
plein de magasins du coup je pense qu'on
avait plus à venir faire de courses ici
c'est très bien parce que le forum
commencé à fermer à côté puis
babou il y en a pas dans le coin un
second souffle pour cette zone
commerciale et en coup de pouce à
l'emploi local sur l'effectif d'environ
une quarantaine de personnes aujourd'hui
parce que le magasin sera ouvert sept
jours sur sept nous aurons environ une
trentaine de créations postes sur la
légende première donc c'était une grosse
volonté de notre part à savoir que nous
venons a vraiment des sportifs
pratiquant connus reconnus sur la zone
et dans les magasins il y avait déjà
foule la semaine dernière en tout le
forum s'étend désormais sur 9000 m² pour
un investissement de 20 millions d'euros
d'ici un à deux mois fly devrait
déménager et être rejoint par l'enseigne
darty à quelques pas de là les
commerçants comptent suivre cette
dynamique le constructeur du forum a
déjà des commandes pour cette zone de 15
mille mètres carrés ni des travaux de
réfection de toute la façade et un petit
peu du parking mais surtout toute la
façade qui va être remise aux six à neuf
pour qu'il n'y ait pas trop de
différence entre cet outil qu'est tout
neuf maintenant éculé bâtiment en face
tu étais un peu loupé ça va être depuis
le départ de castorama en 2009 onze
enseignes sur 15 avait dû mettre la clé
sous la porte
après la rentrée des classes autre
passage obligé en ce début du mois de
septembre les inscriptions aux
associations les premiers forums qui se
déroule dès ce week end samedi c'est le
cas à la verrière et à montigny le
bretonneux bonsoir à béatrice goodman
mais sur ce plateau élu en charge de la
vie associative à la verrière et à
georges derisbourg soir vous étiez élue
en charge avec culture à montigny le
bretonneux des forums particulièrement
important pour les familles chaque année
il faut en général se lever tôt pour
pouvoir s'inscrire dans l'association de
son choix est ce que vous attendez le
même rush cette année on va commencer
par la verrière ah oui tous les ans on a
beaucoup beaucoup de succès avec
certains au club qui attire beaucoup
beaucoup de monde
on a une quarantaine à peu près de
l'association qui sont représentés et
généralement il ya la queue devant les
différences et 14 heures que la verrière
ses 14 heures jusqu'à à peu près 17h30 à
ce moment là on offre un petit discours
du maire monsieur à dire je suis très
attaché à être présents à cet événement
et puis un petit pot d'accueil pour les
bénévoles qui s'impliquent pour
l'événement combien de visiteurs
vous avez estimé et
non nous
et encore plus à montigny les 100 plus
grandes bien sûr donc avons tilly nous
sommes beaucoup plus grand que la vie
hier donc nous commençons à 9 heures
donc un peu plus tôt et nous finissons à
19 heures mais je pense nous attendons
toujours très beaucoup de monde dès
l'ouverture du forum des activités
forcément qui séduisent plus que
d'autres bien sûr nous avons
80 associations culturelles environ et
une cinquantaine d'associations
sportives donc tout ça touche à peu près
quinze mille 15 mille adhérents donc
c'est pas mal et plus comme nous faisons
les inscriptions dans nos deux
conservatoires à l'école de théâtre
à la piscine pour les activités
nautiques donc nous avons beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes qui se pressent
dès l'ouverture mais pour être sûr
d'avoir une place ça veut dire qu'il ya
un secteur associatif très dynamique sur
16 communes c'est aussi le cas à la
verrière au d'associations très
dynamique renouvelée aussi avec des
bénévoles parce que souvent on parle de
crise du bénévolat donc c'est difficile
de faire tourner ces associations c'est
vrai qu effectivement chaque année il ya
peut-être certaines associations qui
peuvent disparaître on aura également
deux nouvelles associations qui sont
présentes cette année je pense par
exemple à un bel os qui sera là je pense
d action sport tas des associations
sportives qui n'était pas existantes qui
lors certaines comme le roller et le
basket sont arrivés l'année dernière
cette année on accueille le
le club saint quentinois d'athlétisme à
saint quentin effectivement là qui
s'étend un petit peu et tout à fait là
il y avait déjà certains adhérents very
roi et du coup m'a aidé c'est de
d'attirer encore plus
d'adhérents donc c'est vrai que le sport
est très très bien représentées on a 8 s
nous sommes beaucoup plus petits gants
bien sûr nous avons beaucoup anne claire
pas de complexe face à cette rivalité
mais c'est vrai que nous avons par
exemple huit clubs sportifs qui seront
présents cette année des associations
socioculturelles également des
associations de solidarité
donc il ya un vaste choix des le théâtre
de saint quentin sera présent également
nous avons le théâtre de chair qui qui
réouvre sur la mgen donc il sera présent
également le scarabée qui vient tous les
ans et qui présente sa programmation
puisque la programmation de scarabées
comment ce 28 septembre
toutes les activités proposées par la
ville notre maison de la musique et de
la danse qui qui étend ses activités
avec cette année un chef de choeur qui
proposera une chorale adulte fap adultes
mais un
adolescent et plus et plus adulte donc
nous essayons nous renouveler à chaque
fois pour coller au plus près des
demandes de la population est ce qu'il
ya des nouveautés à montignac à la
télévision montrent unis il ya des
nouveautés donc je voudrais je vous
rends cité d'octroi donc la première qui
nous tient particulièrement à coeur
c'est une nouvelle association qui
s'appelle coeur d'artichaut l'intérieur
pour les teens voilà donc les hommes qui
travaillent à voir donc avec l'équinoxe
qui recherchent des bénévoles parce que
elle recherche le partenariat entre des
personnes de vécus différents allant
l'équinoxe en reprécisant ça le centre
d'hébergement de réinsertion sociale
tout à fait on a le qe2 situé au nicolas
bour et donc qui va présenter dans les
maisons de retraite en particulier des
spectacles gratuits qui seront
mensuelles voilà c'est une association
j'espère qu'on aura beaucoup d'adhérents
pour pouvoir enrichir cette association
nous en avons une autre qui vient de se
monter bon ça me fait sourire parce que
ça s'appelle le yoga du rire donc le
yoga du rire c'est une association qui
par le rire va permettre aux gens de
s'exprimer et donc elles démarrent cette
association se démarre aidera son stand
donc auprès de l'amicale vietnamienne et
donc elle attend aussi d'avoir de
nombreux adhérents on pourra toujours se
repérer aurait un pur voilà exactement
dans le sens sera opéré au reer pour
repérer des adhérents alors je souhaite
aussi disons ponctué disons cette
présentation par le fait que l'année
prochaine c'est c'est l'année du vietnam
et donc je pense que l'association
vietnamienne nous réservera quelques
surprises au cours de l'année 2014
montini avec un spectacle de qualité
pour fêter pour fêter cet événement
faudra déjà allés chercher les
informations sur leur stand lors du
forum à montigny le bretonneux comment
les municipalités interviennent pour
soutenir justement le secteur associatif
donc vos communes respectives vous
intervenez vous chapeauté déjà il faut
trouver des créneaux horaires des salles
aussi pour les activités sportives les
pratiques culturelles il ya des
subventions aussi qui sont accordées
tout à fait alors à montigny nous avons
à peu près donc je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure 80 associations culturelles et
apprécié une cinquantaine d'associations
sportives tout cela représente 15 milles
à seize mille participants donc derrière
il ya des subventions donc chaque il ya
des règles d'attribution des subventions
qui sont votées chaque année en conseil
municipal cela représente à peu près 240
milles à 300000 euros annuels mais ce
n'est pas tout les associations nous
mettons à leur disposition donc au plan
culturel une quinzaine de
d'établissement ou derrière qui sont qui
se partagent ou qui sont attribués à
telle ou telle association ou qui sont
en partage en fonction des créneaux
horaires elles peuvent s'exprimer aussi
dans les maisons de quartier et bien sûr
les associations sportives ont les
stades les gymnases des salles de danse
la maison des danses etc
et pour la verrière c'est un petit peu
la même chose nous accordons
effectivement aussi les aides et
subventions aux associations
sur des critères très étroites établies
et votée en conseil municipal et puis
nous avons également la mise à
disposition d des salles le prêt du
scarabée nous avons par exemple prêter
le par philippe cousteau quand
l'association portugaise a voulu
organiser un grand rassemblement
de toutes les associations portugaises
locale
nous prêtons des salles dans l'est pour
leurs réunions nous prêtons des salles
pour des des réunions plus régulière par
exemple notre amap celle qui est mise à
disposition tous les jeudis par par la
ville
sans budget important pour une commune
ça représente un budget important
surtout dans la mesure où les budgets
des communes se réduisent un petit peu
et donc effectivement
avoir un ordre d'idée un chiffre sur la
ville derrière
alors je me servais calcule rapidement
s'il s'avère que 300000 euros passant de
l'association sportive et culturelle
beaucoup bougé dans
l'association forcée voilà ces quelques
milliers de vous
pas un ordre d'idée comme ça ces
rouleaux en tout cas d'être venu nous
parler de ce forum des associations je
rappelle que ce se déroulera dès samedi
les modalités pratiques se sont
affichées sur votre écran à elancourt
également attrapé à voisins le
bretonneux vous rendez vous le 7 et puis
à manier les mots guyancourt il faudra
patienter jusqu'au 14 septembre la
semaine suivante merci encore la culture
juste pour terminer ce journal direction
la maison de la poésie qui propose de re
découvrir de façon originale le discours
de martin luther king regardez
le 28 août 1963 raisonner à washington
le célèbre à have a dream cinquante ans
plus tard à guyancourt la maison de la
poésie rend hommage au discours de
martin luther king à son rêve éveillé
d'un monde meilleur elle accueille
jusqu'au 18 octobre une exposition sous
forme d'installations sonores originales
et participative on a demandé à sylvie
gastaud une dentellière du son de
collecter des sens un petit peu partout
ce qu'elle a fait merveilleusement
puisqu'elle a demandé à des poètes et à
des gens de lire le texte de martin
luther king dans une vingtaine de
langues différentes dont du gaulois par
exemple du grec l'espagnol de l'arabe et
caetera et on va retrouver tout ça plus
où le travail d'enregistrement qu'elle a
pu faire dans les collèges et les lycées
les écoles tout au long de l'année sur
la thématique du rêve et surtout du rêve
qui correspond à nos nos missions c'est
à dire montrer que la poésie est un une
parole d'unité une parole de de paix une
parole de réconciliation c'est un vrai
pouvoir civique que possède la poésie et
donc elle le met en avant objets
d'époque band archives poèmes traduction
documentaire autant d'éléments qui
ponctuent la découverte du visiteur ce
qui m'intéressait par dessus tout dans
ce discours c'était les langues
c'était de faire converser les peuples
de travail sur les coûte entre les
langues entre les peuples ou mesfin même
des langues avec les accents je suis
parti avec l'idée d'enregistrer le dit
cependant plein différentes en écho à
l'exposition six ligas d'eau présentera
le 13 septembre au cours d'une
performance sonore et musicale le dream
de babel une proposition du discours de
martin luther king traduite en
différentes langues et accompagner
saxophone
le 7-8 actu revient demain vendredi 18
heures dorénavant sur téléphiles
l'actualité c'est du lundi au vendredi
chaque soir de la semaine je recevrai
demain jean michel coignard le directeur
académique des services de l'éducation
nationale des yvelines pour parler
forcément de la rentrée excellente
soirée vous retrouvez notamment sur
notre antenne ce soir clair qu'en
billets pour un nouveau numéro de fil
échos
vous